whether you are Spanish Italian German
French or whatever your country of
origin is you're welcome here following
the results the referendum I was hugely
disappointed and so I thought I'll just
start a petition oh it was almost as a
bit of a joke it seems to have gone
viral in is gone huge and I think it's
what surprising is there are you know
clearly a lot of people out there who
think similarly to to me I don't think
it's helpful or constructive to make
anymore divisions between London and the
rest of the country so I'm not expecting
London to declare independence anytime
soon perhaps we could get similar powers
to Scotland Scotland is able to make its
own laws on a huge range of policy areas
maybe London now needs something like
that for itself